a
A COUNTEROFFENSE I HAVE AGAINST
R
RUSSIAN FORCES, THE UK
DELIVERING LONG-RANGE MISSILES.
THE URGENCY OF THAT
COUNTEROFFENSIVE BROUGHT INTO ;
a
HALL.
HE WOULD NOT COMMIT TO
SUPPORTING UKRAINE IF HE WINS ;
a
.
UKRAINE OR RUSSIA TO WIN THIS ;
a
WAR?
>> I WANT EVERYBODY TO STOP ;
a
DYING.
THEY ARE DYING.
RUSSIANS AND UKRAINIANS.
I WANT THEM TO STOP DYING.;
a
.
I'LL HAVE IT DONE.
YOU NEED THE POWER OF THE
PRESIDENCY TO DO IT.
>> LET'S GO LIVE TO NICK PATON
WALSH.
THE UK PROVIDING SOME CRITICAL ;
a
NEW WEAPONS.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY SAYING THE ;
a
COUNTEROFFENSIVE WILL BE SOON,
BUT NOT QUITE READY.
WHERE ARE WE ON THE GROUND?;
a
UKRAINE HAS BEEN CLEAR FROM THE
START OF WHAT WE HAVE SEEN TO B;
a
MOST LIKELY PREPARATORY WORK.
IT ISN'T GOING TO DECLARE THE
COUNTEROFFENSIVE AS HAVING ;
a
BEGUN.
ALTHOUGH PROVIDING A TIMETABLE
SAYING IT HASN'T STARTED YET AN;
a
PRESSURE ON WESTERN NATIONS TO
SPEED UP THE DELIVERY OF WEAPON;
a
PROMISED OR BRING MORE.
BRITAIN OFFERING A LONGER-RANGE;
a
.
ENABLING TO STRIKE DEEP INSIDE
CRIMEA.
WHAT YOU HEARD FROM A PRESIDENT
TRUMP, IT'S GOING TO RING
CERTAINLY LOUDLY HERE IN ;
a
UKRAINE.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY, NOT ;
a
SPEAKING DIRECTLY TO THOSE
COMMENTS, BUT SAYING WHEN ASKED;
a
ABOUT THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION;
NEXT YEAR SAYING THAT THEY DON'T
KNOW WHERE THEY WILL BE BY THEN;
a
AND HE WILL BE CONFIDENT OF
VICTORY.
THERE'S A SENSE OF TWO THINGS
HERE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE A DIFFICULT
QUESTION FOR DONALD TRUMP TO ;
a
ANSWER YOU MIGHT THINK
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE POSITION;
a
OF SO MANY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE;
STAUNCHLY IN SUPPORT OF UKRAINE;
a
SYMPATHY FOR RUSSIA IN THE ;
.
HE CALLED PUTIN A SMART MAN WHO
MADE A MISTAKE.
WHAT WH YOU HEAR PEOPLE TALK ;
a
ABOUT A SETTLEMENT, IT SOUNDS
LIKE DIPLOMACY THIS WOULD ;
a
TERRITORIES HERE AHEAD OF THIS
COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
UKRAINE FEELING THE PRESSURE, ;
a
REMOVE PARTS HELD CURRENTLY BY
OCCUPYING FORCES.
ALSO TO POINT OUT THAT WE ARE
DEALING IN A RELATIVELY LIMITED;
a
TIMEFRAM
TIMEFRAME, POLICIES ARE NOT ;
a
.
THAT'S THE POINT.
AND MANY RECOGNIZE HERE THAT TH;
a
CONSISTENCY OF WESTERN SUPPORT ;
IMPORTANT.
>> WEEKS AND MONTHS AHEAD
URGENT, AND MAYBE MORE SO
BECAUSE OF THE POTENTIAL HERE.;
a
A
LIVE REPORT.
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING THE CONVERSATION ;
a
.
ZELENSKYY, IT WAS BEFORE THE ;
a
TOWN HALL, BUT HE SAYS HE WILL
WIN BEFORE THE ELECTION.;
a
INVADED A DEMOCRACY AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED ;
a
REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE FOR ;
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES ;
a
WON'T TAKE SIDES.
WOULDN'T CALL PUTIN A WAR ;
a
.
LISTEN TO TODD YOUNG OF INDIANA;
a
.
HE'S A REPUBLICAN.
THIS IS THE DIVIDE IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY.
RONALD REAGAN'S PARTY PRETTY
CLEAR, DONALD TRUMP'S PARTY, NOT
A PRIORITY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S JUDGMENT IS
WRONG IN THIS CASE.
PRESIDENT PUTIN AND HIS ;
a
GOVERNMENT HAVEN'T ENGAGED IN ;
.
>> THE LEADING PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE --
>> THAT'S WHY I DON'T INTEND TO;
a
SUPPORT HIM FOR THE REPUBLICAN ;
NORMAL NAIGS.
>> THERE ARE A NUMBER OF ISSUES
ON WHICH THE PARTY HAS GONE
COMPLETELY TRUMP'S WAY.
THIS ONE IS A LIVE BALL.;
a
CHRIS CHRISTIE, A POTENTIAL ;
CANDIDATE, CRITICIZED TRUMP ON
THIS.
WE CAN SHOW YOU HIS TWEET.;
a
HE SAYS HE WOULD END THE WAR IN
24 HOURS.
TRY TO DO IT AND ASA HUTCHINSON;
a
THIS WILL BE AN ACTIVE DEBATE ;
THROUGHOUT THE PRIMARIES.
>> THIS HAS BEEN AN ACTIVE
DEBATE ON CAPITOL HILL ABOUT HO;
a
MUCH FUNDING REPUBLICANS ARE
GOING TO BE WILLING TO CONTINUE
GIVING.
AND YOU SEE A LOT MORE
REPUBLICANS IN THE U.S. SENATE
ARGUING THAT IT IS IMPORTANT, ;
a
.
MITCH McCONNELL HAS BEEN ON THE;
a
FRONT LINES OF THIS ISSUE IN ;
TERMS OF FIGHTING FOR FUNDING
FOR UKRAINE.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THAT IS ;
a
WHERE THIS GETS DECIDED.;
CUES FROM THE PARTY LEADERS.
A LOT OF HOUSE REPUBLICANS
BELIEVE TRUMP IS THEIR LEADER, ;
a
SO YOU HEAR THEM LIKE TRUMP.;
>> THIS WAS THE SINGLE MOST ;
a
SHOCKING REVELATION OF THE TOWN
HALL LAST NUGT.
PEOPLE ARE DYING BECAUSE RUSSIA;
a
INVADED A SOVEREIGN NATION AND
KILLED WOMEN AND CHILDREN.;
a
SOVEREIGN NATION IS INVADED BY ;
.
YOU WOULD BE ON THE SIDE OF THE
SOVEREIGN NATION.
YOU CAN HAVE A DEBATE ABOUT HOW
LONG AND HOW MUCH FUNDING AND
HOW MUCH INVOLVEMENT.
THERE'S NOT REALLY ANY DEBATE IN
WESTERN DEMOCRACY ABOUT WHO IS
IN THE RIGHT AND WHO IS IN THE ;
a
WRONG.
NOT TAKING A SIDE IS TAKING A
SIDE.
THE ONLY WAY TO END THAT WAR IN;
a
24 HOURS IS TO PULL ALL U.S. ;
AID.
>> TO GIVE PUTIN THE VICTORY.;
a
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" ;
TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD TAKE THEIR
LEAD FROM THE UNITED STATES ;
a
ABOUT THE LEVEL OF SUPPORT.;
AMERICA FOLDS, WE FOLD.
A GERMAN OFFICIAL, IT COST A LO;
a
.
PEOPLE SAY THAT MONEY SHOULD
BEEN SPENT AT HOME.
BUT IF PUTIN GETS UKRAINE,
WHAT'S NEXT?
DONALD TRUMP SAYS HIS VIEW OF ;
a
RIGHT NOW THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ;
BEEN STILL TRYING TO HOLD ON TO;
a
PEOPLE WHILE MAINTAINING SUPPOR;
.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHEN ;
a
STATEMENTS L